ante la presión de la calle de la
oposición y de su propio partido
Benjamín netanyahu finalmente cambió de
postura
en nombre de la responsabilidad nacional
y para evitar divisiones entre nuestro
pueblo
He decidido pausar la segunda y la
tercera lectura del proyecto de ley
durante esta sesión de la kenneced
para dar tiempo y alcanzar este amplio
consenso
golpeado pero no hundido el Primer
Ministro anunció que el proyecto de ley
se reanudará el próximo mes de abril
después de pesaj la Pascua judía la
posición israelí se declaró dispuesta al
diálogo pero bajo ciertas condiciones
hemos tenido malas experiencias en el
pasado así que nos aseguraremos de que
no haya trucos si intenta algo se
encontrará frente a él a cientos de
miles de israelíes Patriotas decididos a
luchar por nuestra democracia lo mismo
manifestó Benny gangs
nos presentaremos en la residencia del
presidente y le tendremos la mano pido a
netanyahu que no añada amenazas
ultimátums y declaraciones extremas que
nos alejen de nuestro destino detengan
todo y envíen las delegaciones
apropiadas
tras el discurso del Primer Ministro el
principal sindicato de funcionarios
levantó la convocatoria de huelga
general pero el momento del
apaciguamiento no parece haber llegado
todavía dos bandos continuaron
enfrentándose en la noche en las calles
desde la VIP